hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
storage and logistics of vaccines at
ultra low temperatures
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions
you may have during the presentation to
do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
alex esmen
sbs general manager cold storage at
thermo fisher scientific
dr esmen you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much i appreciate that
introduction and
a pleasure to be here today it's really
an honor to be here
and and looking forward to the
conversation and the and the
presentation and the ensuing dialogue
today as well
so to really kick off though it's it's
important to just say
welcome right we are very glad that you
joined us
today uh as jay-z said 20 years ago you
could have been anywhere in the world
tonight but you're here with me
and i appreciate that and and we do
truly appreciate that
uh it's it's a pleasure to have you here
we hope that you get a lot
out of this and we look forward to your
questions
at the end of the presentation
so let's let's go over our agenda for
today we're really going to cover
five topics first we're going to start
off by
talking about this new era in vaccine
storage
that we find ourselves in next we're
going to talk about
selecting the proper ultra low freezer
for the applications that we're
discussing
then we're going to discuss preparing to
receive an ultra low freezer once you've
made that decision and how you
ensure that you are ready to receive and
manage that unit
then we will talk about managing and
usage of an ultra-low freezer
and we'll wrap up with a discussion of
long-term care
and management
so to begin with this new era
of vaccine storage in which we find
ourselves
this is a this is a brave new world this
is a new time
for vaccine storage and management
as we look at where we are for vaccines
now
as as everyone on this call is is aware
i'm sure
vaccines have fundamentally changed
we're now in a world
where we have access to and availability
of
mrna based vaccines which
were not here this time last year
we have viral vector vaccines which have
come to the forefront
of vaccine technologies and these are
really
changing the way that vaccines are
are produced the way they're managed
the way they're stored the way we walk
them
through the entire cold chain
really the biological need of these
vaccines it's what is what's driving
some of these new temperature profiles
again as as many of you know on the
phone minus 70
has never before commonly been used in
vaccine storage
minus 70 is not completely new
minus 70 was used previously
to support the ebola vaccines of the
last decade
however never broadly or what we would
call
commonly used in vaccine storage
now minus 20 has limited use in vaccine
storage and has for many years
more in certain parts of the world than
others
but it is not as broadly used as
refrigeration for and what we what we
mean by
standard refrigeration would be plus two
to plus eight
celsius so
we're going to focus today very much on
the minus 70 aspect of vaccine storage
less so on the minus 20
end of vaccine storage most people who
manage
vaccines and who manage the vaccine cold
chain
are used to managing at minus 20 and or
have some infrastructure in place
to support that to some degree
minus 70 is a different story minus 70
is an infrastructure that is going to
require build out or is requiring build
out
or has been built out within the last
few months
really in anticipation and support
of these ultra low requirement vaccines
so the standard cold chain management
approaches that have been used
primarily focused on refrigeration
are only a small piece or a piece of
what's required
to manage these vaccines standard
refrigerators are are not
going to be up to the task of managing
and supporting all the way through
the cold chain for these for these new
vaccines these new mrna-based
vaccines
so based on the introductory questions
that many of you
answered uh through the registration for
this webinar
uh it's it's it's clear that there are
many people
who don't have a high level of
familiarity
with freezers that are designed
specifically
to support the need for ultra-low
temperatures when we talk about ultra
low temperature freezers and
and i will say that there's never been a
time
when cold chain management at ultra low
temperatures has been more prevalent
in our collective dialogue than it is
now
there have been spikes in time over the
last 20 or 25 years where
it's been part of our conversation to a
degree
but never before has the
vernacular that we use every day been so
impacted and and changed so much
with reference to cold chain management
i don't know about the rest of you on
this call but
i have family members that i don't even
remember having calling me
asking questions about uh vaccine
management
and storage and and cold chain uh
who i who i did not even know were aware
of what i do for a living
so i think we all are probably feeling
that we've seen it
we have friends and family in our
network who are asking us all
questions now and and we're engaging in
dialogue
around cold chain management like we
never have before
and for many of us and for many people
the concept of ultra low temperature
freezers is is a new addition or it's a
permutation
to the understanding of cold chain and
what's required
to support that so an ultra low
temperature freezer
is really a purpose-built freezer that's
designed for
scientific and industrial applications
and needs typically speaking
ultra low temperature freezers are used
commonly between we'll say minus 50 and
minus 80 degrees celsius
and some of the common applications
include drug development and discovery
could be cancer research
self therapy could be basic research
at universities and in hospitals
and the reason that ultra low
temperature freezers are used
is really a question of time ultra low
temperature freezers
increase the amount of time that
researchers
scientists clinicians have
to be able to functionally make use of
biological materials whether that's a
vaccine
whether it's plasma whether
it's a cell line whether it's bacteria
nucleic acid you functionally are
slowing down
a biological clock that's really what
cold storage is about it's about getting
time back and about having time to do
what you need
for many biological materials the the
colder you
go the longer you give yourself the
longer you have
the other aspect of cold storage so the
the aspect of why that time is important
is around the viability
and the the stopping of degradation
of samples and or different things that
need to be stored
so that's why ultra low freezers are so
important for biological research the
colder you take
a sample or a a component
the more time you give yourself on the
clock to be able to
to use that for what's needed and it's
also because
oftentimes you cross thresholds where
molecular time intermolecular
pressures they slow down they change
and it's such that you have longer to be
able to to get something and be able to
have usable time
we have been manufacturing freezers that
do this for over 70 years
there's other companies out there that
manufacture them as well and have been
doing so for a while but we've been
we've been manufacturing ultra low
temperature freezers for over 70 years
they've been around for a while
and what was interesting was when um
the cold chain dialogue began to change
uh mid to late last year
a lot of users
had a lot of questions around ultra low
temperature because it's just not
something that they were used to using
and there was a lot of knowledge growth
that occurred and i think we all saw it
through the news media and other places
around just what are these freezers and
how do they work and
and why are they needed so we've been
doing this for a long time
and they really are designed to very
rigorous requirements and qualification
needs
and we use those terms because
uh some of the customers who have used
these freezers for a long time are in
are in
segments which require uh qualification
validation of performance and and uh
qualification to specific criteria
for equipment that's used in in a
validated process
so these are designed to meet very
rigorous needs
and they are designed to do it uh
repeatably
and uh sustainably and that that last
comment is important around
the fact that over the last few years
over the last couple
over the last decade especially there
have been very good advances within
the science and technology of ultra low
temperature freezers to make them more
sustainable
and also make them more communic
more communicable more more easy to
communicate with and to get information
from and that's also important because
especially as we're talking about
vaccine storage and management the
ability to know what's happening at
any given time with your cargo is key
it's
very important to be able to say i knew
what the temperature was
at time and point a and i know it at
point b
and it aligns with the requirements and
recommendations of
the cdc as well as the who
and other bodies that provide
best practices and requirements and or
recommendations
for the storage of vaccines
so should you find yourself in a
position
where you are going to be needing a
freezer
to store these new mrna vaccines at
ultra low temperatures
uh you need to know what to look for and
you need to know
what questions to ask and you need to
know how to make the right decision
and sometimes that can be overwhelming
when you're looking at a new
at a new thing a new piece of equipment
that maybe you haven't used before
maybe it's new to your fleet or
something that you haven't used for a
long time
sometimes it can be a little
overwhelming to figure out what exactly
is it that you need
the the true north when we are
talking about ensuring that you have the
right product for vaccine storage is
first of all
let the doses guide the way so your
selection criteria for ult should start
just like it would for a refrigerator or
for a minus 20. if you were buying a new
refrigerator for a clinic or a pharmacy
or
laboratory you'd you would choose your
product based on
what you need to store and how much of
it you need to store
so that leads into the second one and
understanding the dosage configuration
understanding what the pack outs for
these vaccines look like
ensuring that you're making the most of
the space that's available
and how to how to really maximize the
footprint
of what it is you're going to need to
store
the other large thing to consider right
when you're looking at what you need is
your electrical requirements and
configurations
obviously discrete regions and in parts
of the world
have specific requirements from an
electrical perspective
but there are also plug considerations
to be made to go along with those
electrical requirements
so understanding that and making sure
that that is communicated through your
purchasing processes is key the last
thing you want is for a unit to finally
show up
and you're not able to actually plug it
into the wall
and that has happened and we don't want
that to happen to you
so understanding understanding your
doses understanding the configuration of
of the vial of the dose itself how
they're packed out whether it's a group
of a hundred a group of two hundred
five boxes that total a thousand uh
whatever the number of vials that you
need to store in the number of doses
making sure that you have visibility and
understand what that looks like
will help you make the right decision so
as we consider the commentary and
and the the storage recommendations from
the cdc around the mrna
candidates and and now vaccines that are
actively being injected
right they're very different so we're
focused primarily today on what was
vaccine and what we know as the pfizer
vaccine
right minus 70 storage
at first right the commentary was around
large sites only we know that that
will and may be changing quickly they
may be also used
at smaller allocations and smaller sites
as well
but one of the limitations that really
is has has pushed and is pushing people
to consider
freezers for the storage of this is the
fact that
the rechargeable shipping container
um is is a dis is a storage can
or is a storage system that some
customers are either not comfortable
with or would prefer not to use
whether it's because of the rotating
cost of of dry ice or the
limitations of the system itself to
manage
multiple openings a day whatever it may
be
um this is uh this is what's driving
some customers to make the decision
to look at and embrace an ultra low
temperature freezer as opposed to
using the shipper itself to manage those
vaccines of course once the vaccines are
thawed there is a usable window of time
within a refrigerator
and once those are reconstituted in a
room temperature
there is a very limited window of time
for usability
so when we when we look at the portfolio
that we offer and this would be this is
true of other manufacturers as well
there is a range of storage capability
the the key is right just to make sure
that you select the product that closely
aligns
to your volume needs and how many
vaccines are going to be processed
per day through a specific
clinic or pharmacy or vaccination
location because there are there are
there are ultra low temperature freezers
to meet just about every
size and number of vials and doses that
that's needed we go from
you know one cubic foot bench top style
ults that are that will hold just under
a thousand vials
up to large um
you know 33 cubic foot units which will
hold
upwards of 300 000 doses so
it's really sizing the product
appropriately
for the need that you have
the difference being endpoint storage
and and
just prior to inoculation potentially
versus what we would call production and
or distribution
hubs so understanding how many doses
you're going to need at any given time
really will help you determine can you
use a smaller capacity product
or do you need something that's a little
bit larger that's designed more for
distribution hubs and or indoor
production facilities
the good news is that all the ranges are
covered
you have options and you have selections
for
the smallest numbers up to the largest
numbers
so coverage exists and it really is
selecting what's appropriate for the
need
that your facility that your health care
system
has and ensuring that that's what you
bring in to support
so you have now
successfully selected a freezer you have
chosen
the freezer that best suits your needs
that best suits the needs of your health
care system
and now you are preparing for that
freezer to
to arrive so what do you do
while you're waiting for that freezer to
arrive well
first of all make sure that you have a
plan for installation
that plan should absolutely follow your
company or your
entities quality management system for
safe equipment installation so first of
all right make sure you're working with
your appropriate people and your quality
management teams and within your
biomedical teams to ensure that you have
and are aware of the the qualifications
for safe equipment installation
and this includes things like making
sure you clear a path
for unit entry seems like a small thing
but understand that depending on the
ultra low freezer that you may have
purchased
there may be some some steric
requirements that mean you need to make
sure that you have a clear path for
entry
unlike what you may have needed for a
under counter refrigerator for example
or for a benchtop centrifuge
there are different needs for these for
these ultra low temperature freezers
other comment here is make sure you have
all your ppe on hand and ready
so you'll notice the gentleman in the
picture is wearing cryo gloves and he's
wearing protective eyewear
you want to make sure when you're using
ultra low temperature freezers that you
have your ppe
ready to go that it's on hand and you're
prepared before your freezer arrives
next ensure you have access to
electrical outlet you're going to need
when the freezer arrives is not when you
want to be
ensuring that there's a home for it you
want to make sure the home is ready for
it when it gets there
this will ensure ease of process and and
will make sure that the
installation goes as well as possible
and lastly on this slide the
recommendation is have your monitoring
system ready
right almost everyone on this webinar is
probably well familiar
with the digital data logger
requirements for
and recommendations from the cdc per the
programmatic playbook for the vaccines
for children program and the safe
handling of vaccines so you want to make
sure that you have your digital data
logger
ready you want to make sure that you
have everything prepared
so that when the unit arrives it can go
in as quickly
and efficiently as possible
a few more things to consider ensure
that the team that's unloading and
creating the unit
has access to all the tools they're
going to need to remove it from
the pallet seems like small things but
small things are often the things that
trip us
up screwdrivers wrenches utility knife
these type of things are
very important have on hand when
removing a unit from a pallet
people may have may be receiving ults
who have never received them before
and so ensuring that they're prepared
with the right tools
will go a long way towards a good
experience
back to the topic of ppe make sure that
the pp is in good condition
you don't want gloves that are ripped or
torn
glasses and face shields that are broken
or cracked
so just check your gloves check your eye
protection for integrity make sure
they're in good functional order and
and functioning properly
make sure that your freezer is on a
dedicated outlet
this is one that sometimes can be uh
difficult given the the amount of
equipment and or the
positioning or placement of the
equipment but it is very important
that freezers be able to have their own
dedicated
outlets and circuits from a from a
nuisance tripping perspective and from a
continuity of performance perspective
lastly from a preparedness perspective
make sure that your freezer is going
into a room that has proper ventilation
um it's it's it's a good practice
to ensure that the units are not
positioned directly under a register
even though even though air conditioning
feels cool to us
consider the fact that air conditioning
to a ult
is about 100 degree differential from
the temperature of that
air that's being blown it blown onto it
as opposed to the inside temperature
so when you open those doors the last
thing you want is
is air that is very warm rushing into
that chamber
causing potentially additional frost
buildup and
and and issues with the storage space so
ensure that you have good proper
ventilation but not
directly into or onto the payload area
of the freezer itself
so you selected your freezer you you
prepared for its arrival
now it's time to actually manage the
usage of that freezer
it's it's in place you've you've plugged
it in
um and you are preparing for vaccines to
arrive
so so what do you need to do how do you
manage the
the everyday usage of an ultra low
temperature freezer
this is again an area where sometimes we
can see
cause for a concern or worry from
customers who maybe have never used a
product like this before
and this is where again we want to we
want to bring people back to
basics and back to a clear understanding
that ulti freezer is is a lot like using
a standard refrigerator
or freezer you want to follow just good
practices
you want to make sure that the things
you are doing are with the good of the
samples that are inside good of the
vaccines in mind
and really follow on those best
practices that that many hospitals and
laboratories and clinics
are already employing today so what does
that mean well
that means when you open the freezer
make sure you minimize the duration of
your door opening
so use a using a system of inventory
management
will allow you to know where you need to
go what shelf you need to go to
and thereby what inner door you need to
open
you really want to minimize both the
duration and the frequency of door
openings
now these units are made to handle
everyday life
they're used they are designed and built
to be functional in in real world
situations
however just like our mom used to tell
us don't hang the door on your on your
refrigerator at home
open and stand there looking for
everything you want to be
fast you want to be efficient and you
want to be very
targeted in how you interact with and go
into
these freezers so trying to minimize the
duration of the door opening
is what's best for the load inside that
unit minimizing the frequency
and just being very targeted is just
another best practice
having a system of inventory management
is is
is just part and parcel with that and
being able to know what you have
where it's located and uh
and knowing every time and having that
documented
is a best practice across multiple
customer types that we highly recommend
and urge
paying attention to what the unit is
telling you is key you'll you'll notice
that ult
that freezer on the slide in front of
you has this nice big
touch screen display that is designed to
tell you a lot about what's happening
inside that freezer
so make sure that make sure that you you
know when you pay attention to what the
unit's telling you
um make sure that you know what the
onboard capabilities are
of your freezer so i would even say as
you're preparing
for your ult to arrive another thing to
consider would be
really familiarizing yourself with the
information about it
right look understand what the product
can do understand what it can't do
understand what it's designed to do
and make sure that you're familiar with
what the onboard capabilities
of your freezer are when you're
interacting with a freezer when you're
opening the doors when you're accessing
the cargo area
of a freezer really only only open the
inner doors that you have to
so for those of you who may not be
familiar ultra low temperature freezers
typically have two sets of doors you
have
a large outer door kind of like a vault
door
and then inside the unit you have inner
doors the inner doors
provide you access to ultimately the
cargo that's stored on the shelves
as we saw in one of the slides
previously
um you want to be smart and targeted
with the inner door that you're
accessing with the inner doors that
you're that you're going to
that again helps you manage and maintain
the performance characteristics and the
and the the temperature performance
throughout the chamber
make sure that uniformity is high
the next thing i would say is
consolidate your cargo
each vial is its neighbor's best friend
when we think about the thermodynamics
of free of frozen samples
um one box surrounded by
friends is a really good thing so
ensuring that your cargo
is dedicated into one space and not
spread out all across the freezer into
smaller bits and pieces on different
shelves
consolidate that cargo so that each of
those
each of those samples provide support
for the other samples around them it's
really a great way to ensure good
uniformity and stability of temperature
within your cargo area
so some more further considerations
take time to learn your user interface
and to manage your most
to manage your most common tasks
there is a massive amount of information
that you can learn from
and glean from the user interface on a
on a ultra low temperature freezer
take the time to to really learn that
and understand what you what you can and
and can't right get from your user
interface
um make sure that you allow the freezer
to
to what we call pull down and soak at
temperature before
starting to load the freezer um it's
typically a good idea for at least 12
hours
most people will will just do it
overnight they'll set up their freezer
and then the next day once it's uh
soaked and dwelled
at temperature they'll start loading it
and we recommend starting with one shelf
at a time and beginning with the top
shelf and then working your way
down the freezer
within our tsx models we have the
capability for onboard connectivity
and there are services that we'll talk
about in
in a coming slide that really a pivot on
and and build off of the
uh potential connectedness of of these
ults
consider connecting your unit and
activating the on board connectivity
as a way to just have more eyes and more
understanding of what's happening
not with your freezer but also with your
cargo at any given time
you just having the ability to connect
your unit it increases your visibility
to status and
operational factors which just gives you
better peace of mind
and a better level of understanding
about how your unit's performing
and i can say with great pride that we
at thermo have been
leaders in connected devices and in
connecting freezers
through cloud-based systems
consider restricting access to your user
to this control settings i should say
um a good practice for any organization
is to establish who's going to be your
administrator and who are going to be
your users for these freezers
and then and then ensuring that um
there's limited access to the capability
to change the settings
on on these freezers oftentimes purely
by accident
a setting can get changed and and and it
can lead to a nuisance alarm
or a situation that could otherwise have
been avoided so just make sure you have
a
hierarchy or system determined
many many uh vaccine clinics
and pharmacies use the vaccine
coordinator as the primary administrator
for these units
and then the staff would be given user
status so there's very limited access to
the cape to the possibility of changing
a setting
that shouldn't be changed lastly really
the the consideration is a maintenance
contract
um it's a good idea up front
and when you are beginning the
relationship with your freezer to
consider a maintenance contract
to ensure maximum uptime to ensure that
over the course and the life of that
product
you have the most possible up time
and and don't have down time where the
freezer is unavailable or unusable for
the
to manage the storage of the vaccines
that you need to store
so the next topic that we're going to
cover is long-term care and management
so we we talked about why you may need a
freezer we talked about selecting the
right freezer
based on the doses and and the and the
sterics of what you need to store
we talked about how you select that
freezer and and how you
prepare for it to come on to your
location and then we talked about how to
manage it every day and how to interact
with it
how to have a relationship with it now
comes the long-term care and management
things to think about that will set you
up for a long good long-term
relationship with your with your freezer
and really it starts out with just a
little tlc can go a long way
within the the user manual
and instructions for usage for any
freezer there
there's going to be a lot of great
information around
ensuring small tasks that can be done to
to ensure the long-term viability of
that product and it's things like
making sure you keep the filters clean
making sure that you keep the gaskets
clean
making sure that the the
batteries get changed out these are
common things
that uh that need to be considered
and they're all located within the user
manual they're all located within the
the documentation that comes with the
product for standard usage
the next thing would be as we as we
previously discussed
consider a warranty upgrade or a service
plan
to really again maximize that up time
and to get a committed on-site response
for your product
we'll talk more about this in the next
slide
but we offer and as well as other
companies but we very much
are are concerned with and want to make
sure that customers have
the most possible uptime and have the
best possible
service response and relationship that
they can have
to ensure that the product is doing what
it needs to do
at all times so with that
always can always have your contact
information handy
for your chosen service provider uh make
sure that it's located on the unit
make sure that it's that it's easy to
find and make sure that it's that it's
always there
so when we think about warranty upgrades
or
service plans um we have
taken steps to ensure that covet vaccine
distribution
providers have opportunities for
prioritization and the fastest service
response possible
we have in partnership with our unity
lab services
portion of thermo fisher scientific with
relation to our tsx ult
freezers really optimized
the potential service experience knowing
that
right now there's nothing more important
out there to be stored and managed
effectively and safely
we offer priority 24 7 support for
our kovid 19 vaccine storage providers
we have troubleshooting and diagnosis
that can be oftentimes managed remotely
over the phone over the web and we have
faster response times available
for this prioritized service we have two
business day service and onsite is our
target for corrective maintenance and
repairs
we offer calibration and temperature
mapping services as well
should you be in a production
environment or or need a unit that meets
a qualification
standard and you need a partner in
walking through that qualification and
through that management
we can manage and we can be that partner
to
provide the need for the needs that you
may have
so we put the long-term
care and the long-term viability of your
process and your samples
at the front of our minds every day so
we both want to provide you a great
freezer and a great experience but we
want to provide you
post that point of sale a great service
experience and a great experience so
that you you know you always have
support
and you always have someone with your
best interests in mind
one of the things which we talked about
previously
which is a part of our tsx freezer
is the ability to have a connected
experience
through our device link technology that
is embedded into our ults
one of the things that we offer based on
this connectedness
is what we call smart connected services
um
i know it's a little bit hard to read on
the slide but our smart connected
services
gives you access to really a dashboard
of knowledge and expertise to to have
eyes on your
units all the time proactively reaching
out
to advise of of a situation if it should
happen
ensuring that you have uh you have
eyes on the conditions within your
freezer
at all times and this is something again
that we offer through our smart
connected services as part of our tsx
freezer portfolio
we are very pleased to have been
industry leaders when it comes to
connected services within ult
freezers and we look forward to
continuing to
to push and and be innovators within the
world of
of what you can learn and how you can
manage your freezers
through a connected experience and have
more peace of mind
and ultimately even more eyes watching
and managing and
ensuring that you have the best
experience possible
so when you think about the advantages
of our
vaccine storage solutions um
we build for purpose we have built as we
talked about and will continue to build
products which are designed with the
best interests and the needs of
of these vaccines and other
pharmaceuticals and
other components in mind at all times
these are purpose-built devices
these freezers and have been and will
continue to be
as the needs and and demands change over
time as the regulations and best
practices change
we change with it and we're happy to be
a partner
with many of these organizations walking
hand in hand
helping establish best practices and
helping establish
standards that are the best possible
standards for the safety of the vaccines
we have a large offering and we're very
proud of that we're very happy to be
able to provide
customers a wide array of product
to meet a wide array of needs whether
you're storing a thousand vaccines
or you're storing 60 000 vials of
vaccines
at a distribution hub we have solutions
that can support and help that and we
have wireless monitoring
options and solutions to help make sure
that the critical parameters are always
managed
and then as we just talked about we have
support mechanisms in place
we have we have our smart connected
solutions
which on our tsx ults can give you a
more robust experience
and if you have questions around it we
also do have our thermo
fisher financial services for leasing
and payment options as well
so with that i want to say again
thank you for your time uh you chose to
spend your time with us here this
morning or this afternoon or evening
based on where you are in the world and
i'm very grateful that you chose to be
here with us
many of the people on the phone right
now watching this webinar
are our neck deep in
patient care situations and situations
where you're dealing with
covid19 every day and and we want to say
thank you we want to say thank you for
all you're doing
and thank you for all you're going to
continue to do and we are honored to be
a company that can help you fight that
fight every day
so with that i'd like to say uh thank
you again very much
and and open it up for questions
well thank you dr esmen for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question
is why is it so hard to store
mrna vaccines uh yeah
it's a great question um the mrna
molecules
themselves um are a little can be a
little finicky
mrna is a species of molecule right
that's found in
in our cells and and it is mrna is the
message
right that connects the nucleic acid
ultimately to becoming a protein that's
going to go do something
um that message oftentimes is not
intended to be a long-lived message
within our cells so ensuring that these
that these mrna vaccines are managed
safely kept safe
it requires oftentimes cold temperatures
to ensure that the rna molecules
themselves
are protected and again it goes back to
that clock that we talked about and
getting more time
so the uh the answer
that that's part of the answer the other
answer is there are there are oftentimes
molecules whether it's lipids or other
type of
small molecules that encase these mrna
molecules that also will help with that
journey
but um it's a very it's it's a difficult
it's difficult to be an mrn an mrna
molecule
and be expected to be around for a long
time
without being managed at colder
temperatures or without being managed
through the assist of other molecules as
well
so that's part of it
okay thank you dr essen we have another
question here what are examples of green
refrigerants
yeah so green refrigerants would be um
refrigerants which support and meet the
requirements
of either the eu f gas requirements and
regulations
the epa standards which are in place and
other regional global
considerations whether it's the montreal
accord the kigali amendment to the
montreal accord
so it's refrigerants that meet the
antenna of lowering the
the gwp and improving
the footprint of freezers like this and
and
products in other industries as well so
examples would be
things like r290
um which is which is used as a
replacement for
older refrigerants which maybe had a
higher gwp and
and and had more of an imprint and left
more of a footprint
thank you dr esmen our next question is
do you have ult for storage bags with
500 by 755 centimeters
oh i didn't bring my calculator um but
uh i i if so give me that dimension
again one more time
um 500 by 755 centimeters
500 by 755 centimeters so uh
i believe the answer to that is yes um
if i did the conf
if i did that real quickly in my head um
my recommendation is to whoever asked
that question i didn't see where that
question was so i apologize
we have people who can reach out and
help you determine the appropriate unit
for the consumable that you may be using
whether it's a vial or a bag
there are very few of those that we
don't have a solution to be able to
support
so based on the quick math i did in my
head the answer is yes we just need to
make sure we figure out which
which unit is the right one for you so
okay thank you again our next question
what's the most common mistake in
mishandling ultra low freezers you've
noticed or come across
and this person wonders if it happened
by you during your tenure at thermo fish
or scientific
so to whoever asked that question um the
answer is
it happened while i was working in a
laboratory so
before i came to thermo i i had the good
fortune to be able to work in
labs for about 10 years the most common
thing we see
is um i would say uh
it goes back to the efficiency with door
opening
and frequency of openings um the most
common thing we see
is is um many many many many many door
openings at a particular time in a
particular window of time let's say
um and that can lead to
that can lead to temperature
fluctuations in the unit as it's trying
to recover from each one of those door
openings and so
um that goes back to the the suggestion
is
um to be efficient to be quick and to
have a system
of to have a system of management so
that you know where
your products are and you can be quick
and efficient with your with your
management
thank you dr esmen our next question is
what is the importance of a rapid
vaccine freeze
what is the importance of a rapid vacuum
freeze so rapid vaccine freezing
typically more important on the
manufacturing side
when vaccines come to a clinic they're
either going to be frozen or they're
going to be in a refrigerated state
and typically they once you once you
pass into a
once you go from a frozen to a
refrigerated to a to a completely thawed
and
useful state the recommendation is not
to go back downstream from there or to
go back upstream from there i should say
so typically rapid vaccine freeze is
most important in the manufacturing of
vaccines
when you're looking at batch freezing
and batch preparation
the answer to that question is honestly
going to be very dependent upon
the criteria of the vaccine that's being
stored so
efficacy studies would need to be
managed to understand
how rapidly does it need to be frozen
what's your leeway and then what would
be the system used in or and or the the
way that you would manage and track that
so okay thanks dr esmen
this person thanks you for the talk and
also ask does
if thermo sells any tools for distance
management of the temperature
i recently acquired one ult and
it does not have device link
yeah so currently um
we do not offer a a system that allows
you to change the parameter on a
on a unit that does not have device link
installed
um remotely um there are some safety
reasons why and there are some other
reasons why as well but that's that's
not something that we offer today
okay great next question does the
geometry and material of a freezing
container for vaccines play
any role for long-term storage in your
freezers
uh so the answer would be yes
but not just in our freezers but in
anybody's freezer
the the reason why
certain vaccines can or cannot be stored
at certain temperatures oftentimes goes
to the limitations
of the of the closure on a vial
the composition of of a vial whether
it's a plastic versus a glass
whether it's a bottle versus a vial the
amount
of sample inside of a vial or a bottle
has a large part to place so so what
impacts the freezing of a sample
the composition of the matrix the
composition of the freezing
vial itself or the freezing enclosure um
and and then the volume right and so
there's there's a lot of different steps
that have impact on to
the freezing profile of a particular
sample
hot increases in in salts and sugars
within a sample
tend to tend to make the the freezing
point go down a little bit
right and so there's uh without this
becoming too much of
a uh of a cryobiology session we are
happy to answer those questions and if
anyone wants to reach out to us offline
we'd be happy to field those questions
so okay thank you dr esmen
we have another question here what is
your opinion on freeze drying of
vaccines and their storage slash
transportation at rt
um i i think that ultimately for
vaccine manufacturers that is the that
is the direction lyophilized forms of a
vaccine is
where a company would want to head
obviously the cold chain gets a lot more
a lot more straightforward a lot a lot
more easy to manage
the trade-off comparables would be is
there a loss of efficacy
is there a loss and and then balancing
that versus the liquid form
um so there's there's some serious
questions that companies have to be able
to manage and answer
around efficacy and and impactfulness of
the vaccine before they would make the
decision to go to a lyophilized form
thank you so much we have another
question here dr esmen
i have been told we should not have our
ultra low freezer open for more than one
minute at a time
and no more than twice a day how
critical are those parameters
yeah that's not actually
that's not actually an accurate
statement so um
ults are designed to be opened multiple
times a day
and even there's customers who may need
to open them
you know once or twice an hour depending
upon the situation
so um if we
these units are designed to be used in
real world settings and real world means
opened more than twice a day in many
cases um
a minute is a relatively long door
opening
however again these units are designed
to be able to manage and support
long door openings within a clinical
setting
average average door opening durations
kind of fall into two buckets
um there's what we call loading times
and and times that we typically see
that it takes to load product into a
unit and then there are the times that
it takes to go retrieve a sample that's
that's going to be used
within a clinical setting um for
refrigerators and freezers
the the first of those right is about
three and a half minutes
to fully load a shelf or to load product
in maybe
it'll say two to three minutes the
the former is typically somewhere
between 15 and 30 seconds
so most door openings can be managed
very efficiently
and very quickly but if a door opening
goes over a minute
it's okay it's there's there's
you may get a door jar or door opening
warning alarm but that's okay that
that's intended to let you know
hey you might want to consider wrapping
up what you're doing
right um but but being able to manage a
door opening beyond one minute
is is a hallmark and trade of these
products that we
that we design and manage to so
okay fantastic thank you um
another question here how do you
accommodate regions with different
electrical specifications for voltage
frequencies etc
yeah so our great question so thank you
to whoever asked that
our products are are designed and built
to international standards for
electrical safety
we manage through uh ce standards with
which includes emc testing we manage
through uh ul standards uh adherence and
testing in the united states and and
others around the world
so our units are are are
put through rigorous testing for
electrical safety
that's the that's the manufacturing side
of it and the safety side of it
we then take to market um units that are
designed to operate
um at at all uh standard global voltages
and uh we manage that through also the
appropriate plugs by region so
if you're in a particular place in the
world uh the probability is very very
high that we not only have the
appropriate electrical configuration but
also the right plug type to match what's
what's in your wall so great thank you
so much
we have another question here how long
how long can we store the vaccine in the
freezer
so if we go back to what we know about
these vaccines so far and what's been
communicated
you can store i believe the i believe
the number right now
is i think you can store the pfizer mrna
based vaccine for
six months in a ult freezer
once it's out of the ult freezer and in
a refrigerator
you have a much much much shorter window
of time you know about five days
and then once it's out of the
refrigerator you have a few hours to use
it
okay thank you next question
how do you consider glass transition
temperatures of a vaccine carrier
eg liposomes for the stable and
long-term vaccine storage
yeah that's a great question that's a
cryobiologist on the phone that's
exciting
so glass transition is a
is an important question thankfully it's
a question that a lot of the
formulations teams
at these vaccine companies spend a lot
of time
um considering and determining
what the appropriate rates of freezing
are and i will say that we are we are
happy to
and we have partnered with a lot of
these companies in the past to help make
those determinations
based on their samples and based on the
the process that they're trying to
implement
so as we talked about before the makeup
of these samples has a massive impact on
how they freeze so
we're talking about additional salts or
sugars you're talking about
the addition of liposomes you're talking
about lip
whatever it may be they will have an
impact on the freezing curve and the
freezing profile
of a vaccine or or any sample
determining what the appropriate rate of
cooling is
um really is a a it's a big effort that
falls onto these formulations teams and
and i don't think enough
credit can be given to them for the work
they do
to to quickly determine
um what the appropriate freezing rate
should be for these samples so um
it's a it's a honor that we get to
support them and work with them
uh because it's a it's a very difficult
thing to
to really determine what does that rate
of freezing need to be
that that is that is the knife's edge
between what's good for a vaccine and
what's bad for a vaccine
so well thank you for that answer dr
esmen
we have time for a few more questions
what is the allowed plus or minus
tolerance for a
minus 70 degrees celsius or ultra cold
freezer
for example plus or minus 5 degrees
celsius
yeah so it's a good question there's
there's a couple different things there
are design specifications that we take
into the manufacturing of a product that
we
hold that product to and it may be
plus or minus five for some models it
may be plus or minus ten for other
models those are typically the most the
two most common ones
uh and and different we manufacture ults
that are designed to really hit
both of those specifications um based on
the engines that they have under the
hood
um what customers expect is a different
thing sometimes and so often
what we have to do is make sure that the
recommendation
it aligns with the need of the customer
so
that is a typical request that we get
from especially validated and qualified
customers who are going to need to
put a unit through pretty rigorous
testing when they bring it on site and
bring it in house and
they will establish through their
processes
what is the most appropriate temperature
what it what are their acceptance
criteria look like
and then we would make recommendations
based on what we have in our portfolio
to meet the needs that they have
so thank you dr esmen looks like we have
time for one more question
why do the pfizer and moderna vaccines
have different storage requirements when
they're both mrna vaccines
well it's a great question um and
it's it's not necessarily a question
that that i
am the best person to answer but
ultimately it comes down to formulation
again and it comes down to
how they are looking at packaging that
mrna molecule
through the process and and and how
they're
how they're shepherding it if you will
through uh the transition to a frozen
state and then ultimately back out into
a into a uh a non-frozen state
um i think you know i i hope that uh in
the coming uh weeks and months we
we understand more and i'm sure we will
but at this point
um oftentimes there are the secrets in
the sauce and
and sometimes we don't know what's in
the sauce right so
thank you dr esmen as we wrap up do you
have any final comments for our
audience uh my my comment again is just
to say thank you to the team
again we we know the work that many of
you are doing and
and we can't thank you enough for um
how how diligently you and how fervently
you are out there helping people every
day so i can't
again just say thank you enough for you
taking some time to be with us today
great questions in the q a i i really
think it's wonderful when we have such a
vigorous dialogue and
i just thank you all for your time and
and i and i wish you the best of days
so and thank you again dr esmen for your
time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye